This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《百分之二》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《百分之二》。也就是数字2的百分之二。欢迎收听《回顾过去》（Look Back At It）播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如在谈论80年代时的马克·拉蒙特·希尔。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难地成长》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身穿盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难地成长》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们动用了大量人力，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个高产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《女性朋友们：相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust Me, Babe）。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. How many times have you heard the phrase, just trust your gut, go with your instinct, or when you know you just know. When we hear those phrases in response to a situation where we really just need advice,
欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友、老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你们能来到这里，收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析的是20多岁时的心理学。你听过多少次这样的话：“相信你的直觉”、“跟着感觉走”或者“当你懂的时候，自然就会懂”。当我们听到这些话来回应那些我们真正需要建议的情况时，
we're feeling uncertain, it can make the situation feel even more confusing, especially if you are someone who is naturally anxious, because feelings of anxiety and a gut instinct often feel completely similar and are incredibly hard to differentiate. Self-doubt, intuition, generalized anxiety, even excitement, they all feel the same. They all operate on the same axis. So how can we ensure that we are making the right choices, that we are choosing the right path, questioning the right things when we can't always tell what to focus on and what to ignore? Well, today, that is exactly what we are talking about. We are going to talk about how to distinguish between intuition and anxiety.
如果我们感到不确定，这会让情况感觉更加混乱，特别是如果你是一个天生容易焦虑的人，因为焦虑的感觉和直觉通常感觉完全相似，而且极其难以区分。自我怀疑、直觉、广泛性焦虑，甚至是兴奋，它们的感觉都一样。它们都在同一轴线上运作。那么，当我们并不总是能分辨出该关注什么、该忽略什么时，我们如何确保自己做出了正确的选择，选择了正确的道路，对正确的事情提出了质疑呢？好吧，今天，这正是我们要讨论的内容。我们要讨论如何区分直觉和焦虑。
And let me tell you, I think it is so important to have this conversation in our 20s because there are so many big life decisions to be made during this decade and so much insecurity and doubt in general. And if we let ourselves be led by fear, thinking that an emotion that powerful must be a a sign. Fear must be a sign. I don't think that we give ourselves the lives that we want. And fear in these situations or anxiety cannot be the master of our fate or the master of our destiny or whatever you want to call it. Knowing the difference between my gut instinct and my fear, it has been a process of trial and error for me. I used to be such a back and forth kind of person.
而且我得告诉你们，我认为在20多岁时进行这样的对话非常重要，因为在这个十年里有太多重大的生活决定需要做，而且普遍存在着很多不安全感和怀疑。如果我们让自己被恐惧所主导，认为一种如此强大的情感一定是个征兆。恐惧一定是个征兆。我不认为我们能过上自己想要的生活。在这种情况下，恐惧或焦虑不能成为我们命运的主宰，或是你愿意称之为命运主宰的任何东西。了解我的直觉和恐惧之间的区别，对我的经历来说是一个不断尝试和犯错的过程。我曾经是一个非常摇摆不定的人。
I would constantly need other people's input. I would take a leap of faith and then I would back down because I began to doubt my own instincts. But around three years ago, I think I experienced just this huge mental shift in general across all areas of my life. And around that time, I basically decided that for three months, I was just going to go with whatever thing I had decided to do first. So whether it was what restaurant to pick, what movie to watch, what person to date, I had to be decisive and I had to base it on my first thought and my first decision. And I definitely got things wrong during that period, but I think I came out of it with such a strong inner voice.
我经常需要征求其他人的意见。我会孤注一掷，然后又退缩，因为我开始怀疑自己的直觉。但大约三年前，我认为我在生活的各个领域经历了一次巨大的心理转变。在那段时间里，我基本上决定，在三个月内，我只遵循我首先决定的任何事情。所以无论是选择哪家餐厅、看哪部电影、和什么人约会，我都必须果断，而且必须基于我的第一想法和第一个决定。在那段时期里，我肯定也把事情搞砸过，但我认为我从中培养出了一个如此强大的内在声音。
And there have been so many times where I have really not trusted my inner voice and been disappointed. And every single time I have been, it's almost been really. reaffirming to me when, like what that sounds like, when it's an instinct, when it's my intuition, and it's so loudly calling me and I ignore it, it feels terrible, but it also just helps me, again, reinforce what that voice means to me and when to listen to it. Now, don't get me wrong, I still experience anxiety when it comes to my decisions, but I think I can now really sit back and appreciate it and have a conversation with my anxiety almost, than allowing it to dictate what I do in life.
有那么多的时刻，我真的没有信任我的内在声音，并为此感到失望。每一次我失望的时候，几乎都让我感到非常。当发生这种情况时，比如当它是一个直觉，当它是我的直觉在对我大声呼喊而我却忽视了它时，这种感觉糟糕透了，但这同时也帮助我再次强化了那个声音对我意味着什么，以及什么时候该去倾听它。现在，不要误会我的意思，当涉及到我的决定时，我仍然会感到焦虑，但我认为我现在真的可以坐下来欣赏它，几乎可以与我的焦虑进行对话，而不是让它左右我在生活中的所作所为。
When we confuse intuition and anxiety, I think a lot of things can happen. We can become very obsessive over particular thoughts that are unhelpful because we think they mean more than they do when really they are just thoughts. We can make decisions because we're panicked that actually end up being ones that we regret. We leave someone we shouldn't.
当我们把直觉和焦虑混淆时，我认为很多事情都会发生。我们可能会对那些没有帮助的特定想法产生强迫观念，因为我们认为它们的意义比实际要大，而实际上它们只是想法。我们可能会因为恐慌而做出决定，最终却成为我们后悔的决定。我们离开了一个不该离开的人。
We turn away from an opportunity we shouldn't. we quit when we shouldn't. Or we don't make decisions that we need to make because we think our anxiety is trying to tell us something. When really, if you think about it, it's just trying to keep us small and it's also trying to keep us safe in a way. These are the mistakes that I want us to make less of. And the thing I'm most excited for in this episode is this questionnaire slash checklist that I have that I use for myself for judging whether a thought I'm having is an anxious thought or an intuitive guide or an intuitive signal. And it's literally one that you could take, you can bring any question, any thought you're having
我们拒绝了一个不该拒绝的机会。我们在不该放弃的时候放弃了。或者我们没有做出我们需要做出的决定，因为我们认为我们的焦虑试图告诉我们什么。而实际上，如果你仔细想想，它只是想让我们保持渺小，并在某种程度上试图保证我们的安全。这些都是我想让我们少犯的错误。在这期节目中，我最兴奋的事情是，我有一份调查问卷/检查清单，我自己用来判断我脑海中的想法是焦虑的想法，还是直觉的指引，亦或是直觉的信号。这绝对是一份你可以拿去使用的清单，你可以把任何问题、任何想法带进来
and you could apply it and put it through this framework and you would have your answer. Is this a thought I should listen to? Is it coming from an anxious place or an intuitive place? I also want to talk about how intuition and anxiety feel in our bodies and in our minds why they're similar, how they're different, when to know the difference, and most importantly, I think, how to truly strengthen our intuition, how to make sure that it is a voice that we hear over the voices of Afia, but also over the voices of a lot of other people who have opinions about our lives,
你可以应用它，并把它放进这个框架中，你就会得到答案。这是一个我应该倾听的想法吗？它来自一个焦虑的地方还是一个直觉的地方？我还想谈谈直觉和焦虑在我们的身体和大脑中的感觉、为什么它们相似、它们有何不同、何时知道它们的区别，以及最重要的是，我认为，如何真正增强我们的直觉，如何确保它是一个能够压倒恐惧声音的声音，同时也能够压倒许多对我们的生活持有意见的其他人声音的声音，
as they always will. So there was definitely a time that I needed this episode myself. Maybe I still need it, but now I get the chance to make it for you all. So I hope you learn something. I hope it makes you recognize something about yourself. I hope it quells some of your anxiety. So without further ado, let's talk about the distinction between intuition and anxiety and how to tell the difference. So let's begin by breaking down how each of these feelings, sensations, how they each work.
正如他们一直会有的那样。所以，曾经确实有一段时间我自己非常需要这期节目。也许我仍然需要它，但现在我有了机会为你们所有人制作它。所以我希望你们能学到一些东西。我希望它能让你认识到关于你自己的某些事情。我希望它能平息你的一些焦虑。所以废话不多说，让我们来谈谈直觉和焦虑之间的区别以及如何分辨它们的不同。那么让我们首先剖析这些感觉、感官是如何运作的。
What is anxiety based in and what is intuition based in? We're going to start with the louder and more persistent or arrogant. of the two we're going to start with anxiety. Anxiety, put simply, is our means to survive. It is the alarm system that is meant to protect us against danger by triggering our fight or flight system. Nowadays, this has also been adapted to include fawn and freeze. Basically, anxiety is the first responder.
焦虑的基础是什么，直觉的基础是什么？我们将从这两者中声音更大、更持久或者说更傲慢的一个开始，我们从焦虑开始。简单来说，焦虑是我们生存的手段。它是旨在通过触发我们的战斗或逃跑系统来保护我们免受危险的警报系统。如今，这也已被调整为包括迎合和僵住。基本上，焦虑是第一响应者。
And they see the incoming danger and they call back to the rest of the body and say, are we going to run? Are we going to fight? Are we going to stay still? I'll be going to make friends. Sometimes, I think we often villainize anxiety because, you know, it is pretty terrible for it to be this constant voice in our head. But it actually is really essential. And it does allow us to see our surroundings properly.
他们看到即将到来的危险，然后向身体的其他部分大声呼喊，说，我们要跑吗？我们要战斗吗？我们要保持不动吗？我们要去交朋友吗？有时，我认为我们经常把焦虑妖魔化，因为（你知道的）它作为我们脑海中不断出现的声音确实挺糟糕的。但它实际上非常重要。它确实能让我们正确地看清周围的环境。
It does allow us to be safe. It is an essential part of who we are. When it becomes a problem, though, is when it starts getting fanatical and making up, stranger and stranger scenarios that aren't actually happening, but convincing us that either they will happen or they are happening. So this is known as a distorted anxiety response. Now there is a way we should experience anxiety. Anxiety can be situation or event based. It can be limited both in terms of intensity and frequency. It is important for our protection. And then there is a way that becomes unsustainable and mentally harmful.
它确实能让我们保持安全。它是我们作为一个人的重要组成部分。然而，当它成为问题时，是当它开始变得狂热，编造出越来越奇怪、实际上并未发生的情景，却说服我们相信它们要么将要发生，要么正在发生。这就是所谓的扭曲的焦虑反应。现在，我们应该以某种方式体验焦虑。焦虑可以基于情况或事件。它在强度和频率上都可以是有限的。这对我们的保护很重要。然后还有一种变得不可持续且对精神有害的方式。
And that is when anxiety becomes constant. We are unable to switch off. And it emerges even when nothing is wrong. So if you've ever been sitting on the couch and you're sitting there and your whole life genuinely feels perfect in that moment, there is nothing scary happening around you. And yet you're sitting there almost being like something's wrong. Something's wrong.
那就是当焦虑变成持续不断的时候。我们无法关掉它。即使在一切都正常的情况下，它也会出现。所以如果你曾经坐在沙发上，你坐在那里，那一刻你整个的生活感觉完美无缺，你周围没有任何可怕的事情发生。然而你坐在那里，几乎就像是觉得有什么不对劲。有什么不对劲。
I can feel it. I know it. You feel uncertain, you feel scared, and you cannot release that feeling. That is disordered anxiety. And it basically turns us into a bunch of conspiracy theorists. We may, you know, look at a relationship that seems perfectly normal and think, oh my God, they're going to break up with me. Even though there are no signs of that.
我能感觉到。我知道。你感到不确定，你感到害怕，而你无法释放这种感觉。这就是失调的焦虑。它基本上把我们变成了一群阴谋论者。我们可能会（你知道的）看着一段看起来完全正常的关系，然后想，天哪，他们要跟我分手。尽管没有任何这方面的迹象。
Or we think that person is so mad at me. Or I'm going to lose my job. Some big disaster is about to happen. and the worst case scenario is about to happen, even when we have no single piece of evidence for those thoughts or scenarios. We end up spiraling, we end up feeling very panicked, there is this desire to do something, this desire to act, this sense of uneasiness.
或者我们认为那个人对我很生气。或者我要失业了。某场大灾难即将发生，最坏的情况即将发生，即使我们对这些想法或情景没有任何证据。我们最终陷入恶性循环，我们最终感到非常恐慌，有一种想做点什么的渴望，一种行动的渴望，一种不安感。
We also start to think that this feeling, because it is so significant, it must mean something because it is so loud, it is so hard to dismiss. And the thing is, is that your anxiety is meant to be loud. Anxiety is not meant to be quiet. It was basically made, it was evolved so that it was hard to ignore because we needed to listen to it for it to be useful because it was meant to tell us something important. But because it is so intense, it feels like everything that it is telling us must be coming true. and it will come true and we need to be prepared and we better be listening to every single tiny
我们还开始认为这种感觉因为如此强烈而必定意味着什么，因为它声音太大了，太难被忽视了。问题在于，你的焦虑注定是要发出声音的。焦虑不应该悄无声息。它基本上被创造出来、进化出来，就是为了让人难以忽视，因为我们需要倾听它，它才有用，因为它原本就是为了告诉我们一些重要的事情。但正因为它是如此强烈，让人感觉它所告诉我们的每一件事都一定会成真。而且它会成真，我们需要做好准备，我们最好倾听它的每一个微小的细节。
piece of thing it tells us even when it's a lie. Now here's the thing about anxiety that I was talking to a friend about this the other day, which is that even like the saying goes that even a wrong clock is right twice a day. So your anxiety is 99% of the time going to be wrong about a situation or a scenario you're in. and then almost by accident, sometimes it will be right. And those are the moments we need to watch out for because we begin to take it as evidence, even though they are so, so rare, we take it as evidence that these feelings we have, which is just simply an overreactive limbic system and our brain trying to interpret the environment,
它告诉我们的事情，即使那是谎言。现在关于焦虑是这样的，我前几天和一个朋友谈过这件事，那就是就像俗语所说，即使是一个坏了的时钟一天也能准两次。所以你的焦虑在99%的情况下会对你所处的情况或情景做出错误的判断。然后几乎是出于偶然，有时它是对的。而这些正是我们需要警惕的时刻，因为我们开始把它当作证据，尽管它们是如此、如此罕见，我们把它当作证据，证明我们产生的这些感觉，其实不过是一个过度活跃的边缘系统和我们的大脑试图解读环境的表现，
we take it as a sign. And then other times our anxiety actually creates a self-fulfilling prophecy, which is one of the reasons we confuse it with intuition. So I'm going to use the example again of you think that a friend is mad at you. You think that's your intuition. It's actually just your anxiety. But because you believe that they are mad at you, it begins to inform your behavior. So you become distant.
我们把它当作一个征兆。然后其他时候，我们的焦虑实际上创造了一个自我实现的预言，这也是我们把它与直觉混淆的原因之一。所以我将再次使用这个例子：你认为一个朋友生你的气了。你以为那是你的直觉。实际上这只是你的焦虑。但因为你相信他们在生你的气，它开始影响你的行为。所以你变得疏远了。
You become cold. You begin to ignore them as a protective mechanism. And suddenly there is a problem. And you're sitting there going, I told you so. Look, my anxiety was right. It was actually intuition. when really what was happening was this irrational feeling has created this behavior in you subconsciously. So about 30% of us are going to experience an anxiety disorder in our lives.
你变得冷漠。作为一种保护机制，你开始忽视他们。突然间问题就出现了。而你坐在那里说，我早就告诉你了。看，我的焦虑是对的。这其实是直觉。而真正发生的是，这种不理性、不讲道理的感觉在你的潜意识里催生了这种行为。所以大约30%的人会在一生中经历焦虑症。
And like the example I just gave, it does shape our behaviors, our actions and our thoughts. It is such a good liar. Our anxiety is such a good liar. But it's also the part of us that is so vulnerable and genuinely afraid. I always think about anxiety as like a parent who tries to shelter their child from the world and tells their child lies like, you know, the sun is poisonous or other people are evil or these people are the embodiment of Satan. Like, you know, when you watch those weird cult documentaries and the parent, like Carrie, for example, like the parent has told them
就像我刚刚给出的例子一样，它确实塑造了我们的行为、行动和思想。它真是一个极好的骗子。我们的焦虑是一个如此高明的骗子。但它也是我们内心那个如此脆弱、真正感到害怕的部分。我总是把焦虑想象成一个试图将孩子庇护在世界之外的父母，对孩子撒谎，比如（你知道的）太阳是有毒的，或者其他人是邪恶的，或者这些人是撒旦的化身。就像（你知道的）当你观看那些奇怪的邪教纪录片时，父母（比如卡莉，举个例子）告诉了他们
something about themselves, not because they hate them, but to protect them because of their own trauma, That's literally how I think about anxiety. This actually brings up an important point, which is the relationship between anxiety and trauma, because we cannot talk about anxiety and the confusion between anxiety and intuition without talking about trauma. So a meta-analysis from 2024, it looked at over a thousand studies and papers written on this topic. Within these papers, there were almost 25,000 combined participants, and it found that, that PTSD makes us more anxiety sensitive. Our anxiety response is deeply informed by our past and the
关于他们自己的一些事情，不是因为他们恨他们，而是为了保护他们，因为他们自己的创伤，这简直就是我对焦虑的看法。这实际上提出了一个重要观点，那就是焦虑与创伤之间的关系，因为我们无法在不谈论创伤的情况下谈论焦虑以及焦虑与直觉之间的混淆。因此，2024年的一项元分析研究了关于这个主题发表的1000多篇研究和论文。在这些论文中，总共有将近25000名参与者，它发现，创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）使我们对焦虑更加敏感。我们的焦虑反应深受我们的过去以及我们所经历的事情的影响。
things that have caused us extreme pain and hurt. And trauma is just going to scramble the parts of our brain that can think rationally about something because if you've been through something really terrible, be it relationship trauma, family trauma, childhood trauma, even like a natural disaster, anything like that, basically that has almost rewired how your brain sees threats and how it sees information because you survived that. Your brain is now almost locked in on those memories and believes that those memories are useful. So the things that you saw right before, I don't know, the boat sunk or right before the relationship exploded, your brain has still got those in storage and is going to bring them out and use them as almost like a tester for what, you know, that experience would
给我们带来极度痛苦和伤害的事物。而创伤只会扰乱我们大脑中能够对某事进行理性思考的部分，因为如果你经历过非常糟糕的事情，无论是人际关系创伤、家庭创伤、童年创伤，甚至是自然灾害之类的，基本上这几乎重塑了你的大脑看待威胁和信息的方式，因为你活了下来。你的大脑现在几乎锁定了那些记忆，并相信这些记忆是有用的。所以你在我不知道船沉没之前或关系破裂之前看到的事情，你的大脑仍然把它们储存在库里，并且会把它们拿出来使用，几乎就像是一个测试，用来看看（你知道的）那种经历会在未来是什么样子。
look like in the future. How do we avoid it, essentially? I feel like that just, I just rambled there and that maybe didn't make any sense. I just like to give the example of being afraid of flying, right? And having experienced a traumatic flying event. That has happened to me. I had a really traumatic fly at once. It was just, I'm not even going to go into details, but it was just so awful. It was so awful. people were crying, people were screaming, it was genuinely traumatic. It may have not led to PTSD, but what it did lead to was a heightened anxiety response in relation to flying. And because I went through that, my brain is now so hyper aware of how scary that felt that that anytime I get on a plane, I'm thinking, oh my God, this twinge in my stomach, that's a sign.
基本上，我们如何避免它？我觉得，我刚才就是在胡言乱语，也许根本讲不通。我只想举一个恐飞的例子，对吧？并且经历过创伤性的飞行事件。这发生在我身上。我有过一次非常具创伤性的飞行经历。那简直是——我甚至不想去细讲，但它太糟糕了。太糟糕了。人们在哭泣，人们在尖叫，这真的是创伤性的。它可能没有导致PTSD，但它确实导致了与飞行相关的高度焦虑反应。正因为我经历了这一切，我的大脑现在对那种可怕的感觉高度敏感，以至于每当我上飞机时，我都会想，天哪，我胃里的这种抽痛，就是一个征兆。
Because I felt anxious when I thought the plane was crashing. And so this new feeling must be like this same feeling that. is actually just a natural response to an unknown, must be telling me something. This is all to say, obviously anxiety is going to feel a lot like a sign sometimes because it is loud, because it is sometimes linked to very emotional, heightened situations, and because it's fear-based and we are naturally prone to listen to fear. Okay, now we really need to discuss intuition. If you want to hear like a full debrief on anxiety, you can listen to.
因为当我以为飞机要坠毁时，我感到了焦虑。所以这种新的感觉一定就像这种同样的感觉。实际上这只是一种对未知的自然反应，一定在向我传达着什么。这一切都是为了说明，很明显，有时焦虑会非常像一个征兆，因为它声音很大，因为它有时与高度情绪化的情境联系在一起，而且它是基于恐惧的，而我们天生倾向于听从恐惧。好了，现在我们真的需要讨论直觉了。如果你想听关于焦虑的完整总结，你可以去听。
I think it's episode 31 on the anxious mind, but now it's important to distinguish between anxiety and intuition here. Intuition is something that is sometimes lumped in with a bunch of other concepts. Paranoia, cognitive biases, emotional thinking, anxiety, of course, a gut instinct, our inner voice. Whatever you want to call it, whatever people confuse it as, basically intuition describes the way that we can just sense that something is not quite right without needing. rational proof in that moment. It is this strange ability to pick up on cues from another person
我想那是关于焦虑心理的第31集，但现在在这里区分焦虑和直觉是很重要的。直觉有时与一堆其他概念混杂在一起。多疑、认知偏见、情绪化思维、焦虑，当然还有肠道直觉、我们的内在声音。无论你想怎么称呼它，无论人们把它混淆为什么，直觉基本上描述了这样一种方式：我们无需在当时有理性的证据，就能感觉到有些事情不太对劲。这种奇怪的能力能够捕捉到来自另一个人或我们的环境或我们的感官的线索
or our environment or from our senses that is telling us something that might not be something we can admit to ourselves or we can say out loud, but we can feel it. So I found this really amazing article that kind of broke down the four types of intuition. So there's clairvoyance, which is kind of almost having visions or seeing images of something that's about to happen, honestly quite spiritual, very rare. There's clair sentience, which is like a gut reaction that could include feeling really intense bodily sensations or feelings. There's clear cognizance, which is when you're kind of sitting there and you just feel
这告诉我们一些事情，这些事情可能不是我们能对自我承认的，也不是我们能大声说出来的，但我们能感觉到它。所以我发现了一篇非常棒的文章，它将直觉分为四种类型。所以有透视力（clairvoyance），这几乎有点像有远见或者看到即将发生的事情的图像，老实说非常精神层面，非常罕见。还有超感官知觉（clair sentience），就像是一种肠道反应，可能包括感受到非常强烈的身体感觉或情感。还有明悉力（clair cognizance），就是当你坐在那里，突然感觉到这种知识落入你的脑海中。
this like piece of knowledge drop into your head. One example I give as people who say they knew the queen was going to die the day before she did. it felt like this weird intuitive, oh my God, like mystical thing. And then there is clear audience, which is hearing short phrases, voices, sounds that feel like some kind of direct message. Obviously, there's a lot of overlap with that last one with schizophrenia or schizoaffective disorder. Essentially, it's just how you hear your intuition when your intuition is at a normal, balanced level.
我举的一个例子是那些说他们在女王去世前一天就知道她会去世的人。感觉这就像是一种诡异的直觉，哦天哪，就像是某种神秘的事情。然后还有超听力（clair audience），就是听到简短的短语、声音、听起来像是某种直接信息的声响。很明显，最后一种与精神分裂症或分裂情感性障碍有很多重叠之处。本质上，这只是当你的直觉处于正常、平衡的水平时，你如何听到你的直觉。
Now, some people are going to define intuition as a very spiritual. spiritual or magical phenomenon. And until about 20 years ago, the scientific community would have probably agreed and it would have told you that it was garbage and it was just mystical thinking. But more and more evidence is coming out that points to the fact that our gut instinct and our intuition has a very strong scientific basis. And it does occur on almost a cellular level, on a social level, a physical level and a collective level as well. I personally have a deep belief in intuition, if that is not obvious.
现在，有些人会将直觉定义为一种非常精神的或神奇的现象。直到大约20年前，科学界可能会同意这一点，并会告诉你那是垃圾，那只是神秘主义的思考。但越来越多的证据浮出水面，指出我们的肠道直觉和直觉有着非常坚实的科学基础。而且它几乎发生在细胞层面、社会层面、物理层面以及集体层面。如果这还不够明显的话，我个人对直觉有着深深的信仰。
I'm going to tell you about this crazy story that actually happened to me that felt like intuition at work and probably even saved my life. So around five years ago, I was living in Canberra and it was around 11 p.m. at night, almost 12, and me and my boyfriend at the time decided to go and get McDonald's, like a drive-thru McDonald's. I don't know why. I think we just were like, we'd watched a movie, we were still awake, we really felt like a McFaright. Honestly, that's just a silly detail.
我要跟你们讲一个发生在我身上的疯狂故事，感觉就像是直觉在发挥作用，甚至可能救了我的命。大约五年前，我住在堪培拉，当时大约是晚上11点，快12点了，我和当时的男朋友决定去买麦当劳，就像是得来速（drive-thru）麦当劳。我不知道为什么。我想我们当时只是觉得，我们看了一部电影，还醒着，非常想吃麦当劳薯条。老实说，这只是一个愚蠢的细节。
You don't need to know that. We go through this drive-thru, we pull out, and we pull into this like four-way intersection with two lanes going either way. We pull up to the light. There are no other cars around. We're listening to music. And the light for me to turn right at this intersection goes green. and I'm sitting there and I just don't go forward.
你不需要知道那个。我们穿过这个得来速，开出来，然后驶入这个四岔路口，两边各有两个车道。我们把车开到红绿灯前。周围没有其他汽车。我们在听音乐。这个路口允许我右转的绿灯亮了。而我坐在那里，就是没有往前开。
And my boyfriend at the time looks at me and goes, what are you doing? Like, why aren't you moving? And I kind of just looked at him and was like, oh, I don't know. Right at that point, I turned back to the road and I went to go forward and at that very moment, this car going probably around 100 kilometres an hour, ran the red light and would have completely hit us. It would have hit us and it probably would have killed us. And right behind it, these three to four cop cars pull onto the road and are chasing it. And we are just sitting in the car and I'm just like, holy crap. If I had pulled out onto that road, we would have died. We would have died.
当时的男朋友看着我问：“你在干嘛？为什么不走？”我有点看着他然后说：“哦，我不知道。”就在那个时候，我转头看向马路，正准备往前开，就在那一瞬间，一辆时速可能达到100公里的汽车闯了红灯，本会迎面撞上我们。它会撞上我们，而且很可能会要了我们的命。就在它后面，三到四辆警车冲上马路在追赶它。而我们只是坐在车里，我当时的心情就是，天哪。如果我把车开上那条路，我们就会死。我们就会死。
This car would have hit us directly where him and I were sitting and it would have just been the end. And that's, like, we literally pulled over and we're just like in shock. Like, I cannot even explain that feeling of just being like, wow. And later that, then we called our friend, I don't even know what happened. I think we like texted our friends and we're like, you're not going to believe what just happened. And they go on the news and they go into like our local news page in Canberra. And there's a car that has been like in pursuit by the police. And an hour later, like it's been basically it's a high speed chase. And I don't know what it was in that moment when, you know,
这辆车会直接撞上我和他坐的地方，一切就都结束了。然后呢，我们把车停在路边，处于震惊状态。我甚至无法用言语来形容那种感觉，就是“哇”。后来，然后我们给朋友打电话，我甚至不记得发生了什么。我想我们给朋友发了短信，说：“你们绝对不会相信刚刚发生了什么。”他们查看了新闻，上了堪培拉当地的新闻页面。有一辆车一直在被警察追捕。一个小时后，基本上这是一场高速追逐。我不知道那一刻是什么让我，
I'm in the car listening to music and the light turns green and I see it turn green and I did not go. And some part of me says that was just intuition. The thing is, I'm quite a scientific person. I love the science. I love the evidence. And for a while I was really trying to find an answer because how do we explain moments like that? We've all had a moment like that.
我坐在车里听着音乐，灯变绿了，我看到它变绿了，但我没有走。我内心的一部分觉得那就是直觉。问题是，我是一个相当注重科学的人。我热爱科学。我热爱证据。有一段时间，我一直在努力寻找答案，因为我们该如何解释这样的时刻呢？我们都有过这样的时刻。
There are a few theories as to what causes this intuition that stops us or tells us to go or is like a calling. The first explanation is obviously one of fate and destiny and mysticism and a higher power controlling everything. Call it God. The universe Allah, some power is moving all these parts. Now this one's hard to prove, obviously, because it's hard to prove the existence of something you can't and that doesn't have a scientific measure to it, but that's one take on it. The psychology, though, says two things. Intuition is this emotionally charged, rapid, unconscious process
关于是什么导致了这种直觉阻止了我们、告诉我们前进或者是一种召唤，有几种理论。第一种解释显然是关于命运、宿命、神秘主义以及控制一切的高等力量。称之为上帝。宇宙，真主，某种力量在推动着所有这些部分。现在这个很难证明，很显然，因为很难证明你无法感知且没有科学衡量标准的事物的存在，但这是一种看法。然而，心理学说的是两件事。直觉是一种充满情感的、快速的、无意识的过程
whereby our brain is basically using information that we've never acknowledged or seen before to influence our actions. So basically, when we look at the world, our brain is really good at just selecting what is important to us because we do have, finite cognitive resources. It cannot process every single little thing in our environment at once and give all that information to us to consciously process. All that information though, it still exists and it's still being processed. You may not consciously have noticed the car speeding down towards you, but part of your brain did and told you to stop. You may not have
通过这个过程，我们的大脑基本上在利用我们从未承认或见过的信息来影响我们的行动。所以基本上，当我们看世界时，大脑非常擅长只选择对我们重要的事情，因为我们确实拥有有限的认知资源。它无法一次处理环境中的每一个小细节，并将所有这些信息提供给我们进行有意识的处理。然而，所有这些信息依然存在，并且仍在被处理中。你可能没有有意识地注意到那辆朝你疾驰而来的汽车，但你大脑的一部分注意到了，并告诉你要停下。你可能没有
consciously seen the suspicious shadow in the alleyway. Some part of your brain. did and it kind of cut over all the noise and said don't go down there don't go forward don't do that thing that's the first explanation basically your unconscious mind noticing things quicker than you faster than you silently the second explanation is based on learning and how our brain really predicts things based on past experience and yeah basically it learns from what we've been through before so this is the theory that was put forward by the neuroscientist Joel Pearson. He runs a lab on neuroscience and intuition called Future Mind Labs at UNSW here in Sydney. And I'm going to explain this explanation the way he does, which is using a coffee shop. So you write a new coffee shop. Let's say you're
有意识地看到小巷里可疑的阴影。你大脑的一部分注意到了，它有点盖过了所有的噪音，说不要走那边，不要往前走，不要做那件事，这就是第一个解释，基本上你的无意识大脑比你更早、更快、默默地注意到了事情。第二个解释基于学习以及我们的大脑如何根据过去的经验真正预测事情，是的，基本上它从我们以前经历过的事情中学习。所以这是神经科学家乔尔·皮尔逊（Joel Pearson）提出的理论。他在悉尼新南威尔士大学（UNSW）运营一个名为“未来心智实验室”（Future Mind Labs）的神经科学与直觉实验室。我将用他解释的方式来解释这个解释，也就是用咖啡店作比喻。所以你来到一家新的咖啡店。假设你
walking around London, you're walking around Brazil, you're walking around Tokyo, some city, you've never been before. And you want to get a coffee, you want to get some lunch. Now, you've been to heaps of cafes before. And when you were in those environments, your brain processed all of these pieces of information, the temperature, the music, the coffee machine, how clean the floor was, the decor, how warm it was. And you've just basically learned what parts of an atmosphere or an, or an environment are going to predict the kind of food and experience and coffee that you want based on all these prior learnings. So as you're looking for a cafe, you're standing in the entrance, your intuition is applying those learnings to all this conscious information that's
在伦敦闲逛，在巴西闲逛，在东京闲逛，某个你从未去过的城市。你想喝杯咖啡，想吃点午餐。现在，你以前去过无数的咖啡馆。当你身处这些环境时，你的大脑处理了所有这些信息，温度、音乐、咖啡机、地板有多干净、装饰、有多温暖。你基本上已经了解了一处氛围或环境的哪些部分，能够根据所有这些先前的学习，预测出你想要的食物、体验和咖啡。所以当你寻找咖啡馆时，你站在入口处，你的直觉正在将这些学习应用到此时此刻正在发生的所有有意识的信息中，以帮助你根据直觉做出决定。这就是为什么你可能会对一个坏朋友或某人在对你撒谎产生直觉。那是因为你可能以前遇到过这种情况。
happening right now to help you make a decision based on a gut feeling. This is why you might have a gut instinct about a bad friend or that someone is lying to you. It's because you've probably encountered a situation before. And although you may not have picked up on some of the information that came with this situation, part of your brain did. And now it's pulling that information out of storage to help you make the best decision in this moment now. There is another component of intuition, and it's talked about a lot less, and it's this kind of ancient kind of knowledge. Knowledge passed down through generations that feels like it's in our DNA, even in ourselves. You may not have encountered a situation before, but there is some
虽然你可能没有注意到随这种情况而来的某些信息，但你大脑的一部分注意到了。现在它正在把这些信息从记忆库中提取出来，帮助你在此时此刻做出最好的决定。直觉还有另一个组成部分，它受到的讨论要少得多，那就是这种古老的知识。代代相传的知识，感觉它存在于我们的DNA中，甚至在我们的细胞里。你以前可能没有遇到过这种情况，但你身上有一些人性化的部分，对它感到非常熟悉，并且知道如何行动，带有一种似曾相识的感觉。老实说，我认为这是因为你的过去有一些祖先、有一些经历存在于你的血液中、存在于你的骨骼中、通过你代代相传。你可以称之为精神，你可以随便怎么称呼它。我知道这听起来非常迷信。这是一种古老的人类知识，它塑造了你看待世界的方式，并塑造了你的直觉和肠道直觉。
human part of you that feels very familiar with it and knows how to act and some kind of of deja vu. I honestly think it's because there's some ancestor, some experience from your past that it's in your blood, it's in your bones, it's been passed down through you. You can call it spirit, you can call it whatever. I know this sounds very woo-woo. It's an ancient human knowledge that informs how you see the world and informs your intuition and your gut instinct. I want to tell another story this time about my mom. When she was my age, she was traveling around the world, doing fun, fabulous things. And she was in Indonesia.
我想讲另一个故事，这次是关于我妈妈的。在她像我这么大时，她周游世界，做着有趣、精彩的事情。当时她在印度尼西亚。
She was on a mountain that she knew was an active volcano. And it hadn't explored for a while. I think it was semi-dormant. She's walking up this volcano, doing this hike. And she just gets the sense that this is going to erupt. Something's not right. And she runs down the mountain. She sprints down the mountain and it erupts.
她在一座她知道是活火山的山上。它已经有一段时间没有爆发了。我想它处于半休眠状态。她正走在这座火山上进行这次徒步旅行。她突然有一种感觉，这要爆发了。有些不对劲。她跑下山。她冲下山，然后它就爆发了。
like, I don't know if it was the day later. It was after she got down the mountain. But within a very short period of time, the volcano had erupted. And from what I can remember of this story, no one was there with her. No one had told her. She just had this very human sense. And it was almost like some ancestors,
就像，我不知道是不是一天后。那是她下山之后。但在很短的时间内，火山就爆发了。根据我对这个故事的记忆，当时没有人陪着她。没有人告诉过她。她只是有这种非常人性化的感觉。这几乎就像某些祖先，
some human person in her past had encountered this. And there was a knowledge there that was passed on. And I remember her telling me, she felt like she needed to move and she needed to hustle, but she didn't feel anxious about the thought. She didn't feel like there was anything to do other than to act. She was very certain. And I think this is what intuition feels like. It feels very calm and self-assured. There is no doubt. There is not a thousand possible outcomes or explanation running through your head. The way that that, you know, that's sometimes what happens with anxiety.
她过去的一些人类经历遇到了这种情况。那里有一种知识被传了下来。我记得她告诉我，她觉得自己需要行动，需要赶快离开，但她对这个想法并不感到焦虑。她不觉得除了行动之外还有什么可做的。她非常确定。而我认为这就是直觉的感觉。它感觉非常平静和自信。没有任何怀疑。没有一千种可能的结局或解释在你的脑海中盘旋。有时候焦虑就是这样的情况。
You're sitting there. Oh, like, this could happen or this could happen or this could happen. It's serving you up a thousand different possibilities. With intuition, that's not the case. There's one explanation, one prediction. You feel it in your body. It is stable. It is certain.
你坐在那里。哦，比如，这可能会发生，或者那可能会发生，或者那可能会发生。它为你提供了一千种不同的可能性。有了直觉，情况就不是这样了。只有一个解释，一个预测。你在身体里能感觉到它。它是稳定的。它是确定的。
It is confident. Most people also obviously say you can feel it in your stomach. That's the term gut instinct. That's where it comes from. Now, the science behind this sensation is very, very cool. Scientists don't call the stomach the second brain for no reason. There's very good reason because there is a vast neural network of over 100 million neurons lining your entire digestive system.
它是自信的。大多数人显然也说你可以在胃里感觉到它。这就是“肠道直觉”这个词的由来。这就是它的来源。现在，这种感觉背后的科学非常、非常酷。科学家们称胃为“第二大脑”不是没有原因的。这是有充分理由的，因为在你的整个消化系统内衬着一个由超过1亿个神经元组成的庞大神经网络。
And every single year, more and more evidence emerges that there is this bidirectional communication pathway between the brain and the gut. In other words, you might feel your, emotions or certain sensations in your stomach before you consciously process them. They're known by another name. They're called gut signals and a 2020 paper looked at whether they could be trusted. And it did find that emotional stress and cues have an immediate impact on the gut in a way that we may be quicker to recognize than a passing thought or than any other kind of sensory
而且每一年，越来越多的证据表明，大脑和肠道之间存在着这种双向交流的通路。换句话说，你可能会在你有意识地处理它们之前，在你的胃里感受到你的情绪或某些感觉。它们有另一个名字。它们被称为肠道信号，2020年的一篇论文研究了它们是否值得信赖。它确实发现，情感压力和线索对肠道有着直接的影响，这种影响可能比转瞬即逝的想法或任何其他类型的感觉信息
information. That's what the gut instinct is. As to whether we can trust our intuition, I can't go into all the studies because there are so, so many. And the answer is, it really depends. It really depends. But by and large, we do need this part of ourselves, this unconscious intelligence. A 2006 study that I read that looked at this found that people were better able to make a decision, under like chaotic circumstances when they went with what they initially thought, rather than those situations where they had time to really think about it, especially when we have more options. So if we're thinking about intuition and a big life choice,
让我们更快地识别出来。这就是直觉。至于我们是否能相信我们的直觉，我无法涉及所有的研究，因为实在、实在是太多了。答案是，这真的取决于情况。这真的取决于情况。但总的来说，我们确实需要自己身上的这一部分，这种无意识的智慧。我读过的一项2006年的研究发现，在混乱的情况下，当人们遵循他们最初的想法时，比那些有时间真正思考这些情况的人（特别是在我们有更多选择时）更能做出好的决定。所以如果我们考虑直觉和一个重大的生活选择，
especially one in our 20s, if you just applied reason and rationality to however many choices you have, you would not make a good decision because you would get too caught up in the data. There are certain moments like that one. where you have to just trust what is being fed to you, what information that you may not be able to label is being told to you that is helping you make a choice. I also think, you know, human emotion and to some extent,
特别是在我们20多岁的时候，如果你只是将理由和理性应用于你所拥有的任意多的选择，你将无法做出好的决定，因为你会陷入数据中无法自拔。在某些时刻，比如那一个。你必须只相信正在喂给你的东西，那些你可能无法贴上标签但正在告诉你、帮助你做出选择的信息。我也认为，（你知道的）人类的情感在某种程度上，
human relationships aren't always properly represented in rational thought. There are things about human relationships that cannot be presented in facts or figures or pro-cons lists. And so listening out for that emotional directive that you'll, are being given and whatever direction you're being called to is really, really important. Otherwise, you end up confused, robotic, almost mathematical at times. The question now is, how do we tap into that inner voice when sometimes it does just feel like anxiety? We spend a lot of time talking about both of those things.
人际关系并不总能在理性思维中得到恰当的体现。人际关系中有些东西是无法用事实、数字或利弊清单来呈现的。因此，去倾听你所收到的那种情感指引，以及无论你被召唤去往哪个方向，都是非常非常重要的。否则，你最终会感到困惑、像机器人一样，有时甚至近乎数学般机械。现在的问题是，当我们有时觉得那只是焦虑时，我们该如何顺应那个内心深处的声音呢？我们花了很多时间来探讨这两件事。
Let's put it together after this very short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator of available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are
在非常短暂的广告之后，我们继续探讨。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带你抛开主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，
freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What The hell does George Bush got to do a little count? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》，即TWO percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什他妈的跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集节目中，我们都会来到这里，剖析发生的事件，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，不过只是让大家知道我的态度。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在了台面上。
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
谢谢你把那句话说完。对。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, this month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，这个月我将把我十多年来在心理健康领域的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要？你当一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、
pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle
压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战，
to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through, the same thing. Grega lesbian, Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马拉尼尼。我的世界观崩塌了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。作死就会付出代价。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》这个全新的季度中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So knowing what we know now, why do we confuse intuition and anxiety? Well, we are. often confuse them because they feel the same and they elicit very similar thoughts and sensations. In particular, if you are someone who is already anxious, you are going to be hypervigilant
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。所以，结合我们现在所了解的，为什么我们会把直觉和焦虑混淆呢？嗯，我们之所以经常把它们混淆，是因为它们感觉很相似，并且会引发非常相似的想法和感觉。特别是如果你本身就是一个容易焦虑的人，你就会变得高度警惕，
to even the smallest cues or signs of danger or signs that you should or shouldn't be doing something. And so your brain is going to naturally apply a deeper meaning to things that sometimes is just fear, sometimes it's just catastrophic thinking, sometimes it's just worry. and we confuse those sensations for an intuitive thought. Here are some of the other reasons that we tend to get them confused. I think, to start off with, they both often occur in response to uncertain situations. And so with both intuition and anxiety,
甚至对最微小的危险信号或迹象，或者暗示你该做或不该做某事的迹象保持敏感。因此，你的大脑自然会赋予那些有时仅仅是恐惧、有时只是灾难化思维、有时只是担忧的事情更深层的含义。而我们却把这些感觉误认为是一种直觉。以下是我们容易将它们混淆的其他一些原因。我想，首先，它们往往都是在面对不确定情况时发生的。因此，无论是直觉还是焦虑，
they often are going to come up when there is some kind of unknown. And that's something we never enjoy as humans. And because in that situation, we're already stressed, it can be hard to tell the difference. They can both often feel a little bit irrational. Like, I don't know why I feel this way, I just do. In terms of anxiety, the reason you just feel this way is because your mind is, I don't know, just on high alert and dysregulated in terms of how you're processing fear.
当出现某种未知情况时，它们通常都会涌现。而这是我们人类永远都不喜欢的东西。而且因为在这种情况下我们已经处于压力之中，所以很难分辨出两者的区别。它们有时都让人感觉有点不理性。比如，我不知道我为什么会有这种感觉，我就是有这种感觉。至于焦虑，你之所以会有这种感觉，是因为你的大脑——我不知道——处于高度戒备状态，并且在处理恐惧的方式上失调了。
In terms of intuition, sometimes it's because you're just seeing something that your brain isn't consciously knowing is there. They also both originate from within us. even if it's different corners of the mind. If anxiety was all situation-based or was just what someone else had to say, it would be very easy to discredit it. But because both of them,
至于直觉，有时是因为你看到了某种东西，而你的大脑并没有有意识地意识到它的存在。它们也都源自我们内心，即使是在心灵的不同角落。如果焦虑完全基于某种情况，或者只是别人的一面之词，那要否定它就非常容易了。但因为它们两个——
intuition and anxiety, are coming through some of the same channels, they can get kind of confused. They also, like I said, elicit some of the same physical sensations, specifically that gut signal or sensation. For anxiety, that can feel like nausea. Sometimes that feels the same.
直觉和焦虑，都是通过相同的某些渠道传达出来的，所以它们有时会被混淆。正如我所说，它们还会引发一些相同的身体感觉，特别是那种肠胃的信号或感觉。对于焦虑来说，那可能感觉像是恶心。有时这种感觉与直觉完全一样，所以很容易被混淆。它们也都让人觉得有必要去倾听。因此，尽管我们有点讨厌焦虑的感觉，但它确实是一种重要的感觉，而且我们的大脑很难忽视它。直觉也是如此。
as a gut instinct, so it's easily confused. They both also feel important to listen to. So as much as we kind of hate an anxious feeling, it is an important feeling and it's very hard for our brain to ignore it. The same with intuition. It's there, they're loud, and often they are directed towards something that feels emotionally salient to us. We're not going to feel intuitive or anxious about what bag to take to the gym or what pen
它们就在那里，声音很大，而且通常都指向某种对我们而言在情感上很显著的事情。我们不会对该带哪个包去健身房或用哪支笔这样的小事感到直觉或焦虑。我们会对那些非常深刻的大事感到焦虑和直觉，比如财务、人际关系、人生选择。所以它们处于同一个生态系统中。最后，它们都试图引导我们做出某个决定。直觉希望我们做一个好的决定。焦虑则希望我们做出能确保我们安全的决定。无论哪种方式，它们都在我们大脑中发挥作用，为该走哪条路提供最好的论据。我们已经讨论了它们的相似之处。那它们有什么不同呢？这才是我们真正想知道的。
to use. We're going to feel anxious and intuitive about very profound big things like finances, relationships, life choices. So they sit in the same ecosystem. And finally, they're both trying to guide us to make a certain decision. Intuition wants us to make a good decision. Anxiety wants us to make the decision that keeps us safe. Either way, they're both working on our brain to kind of give it the best argument as to what path to take. We've talked about how they're similar. How do they differ? This is the real thing we want to know.
嗯，如果说焦虑是急迫和匆忙的，并且总是让你觉得需要立刻采取行动，就像一个管理时间方式糟糕的糟糕老板一样；那么直觉则会让你放慢节奏。直觉不会催促你。它不会逼迫你仓促做出决定，哪怕这是一个重要的选择。我发现，直觉还让人感觉异常地
Well, where anxiety is urgent and rushed, and it will always make you feel like you need to do something immediately, like a bad boss with a bad way of time management, intuition is going to let you take your time. Intuition will not push you. It will not rush you towards a decision, even if it's an important choice. Intuition I've found also feels remarkably
平静。它就像是你全身的一种平稳感觉，有一种真正笃定的感觉，比如：“是的，这就是我需要做的。”有时你甚至会觉得：“我无法解释。我就是知道，而且这并不可怕。这只是一种认知。”另一方面，焦虑往往让人非常不舒服。会有很多的焦躁不安。有很多的紧张。它是运动。它是混乱。它是能量。正如我们之前所说，这也是一个重要的区别。直觉是单数的。焦虑是复数的。直觉通常会给你一个答案、一种情境、一个假设，而焦虑
calm. It's like this steady feeling in your whole body, this like real sense of like, yeah, this is what I need to do. And sometimes you even are just like, I can't explain it. I just know and it's not scary. It's just knowledge. On the other hand, anxiety tends to be very uncomfortable. There's a lot of restlessness. There's a lot of jitteriness. It's movement. It's chaos. It's energy. Like we said before, this is also an important distinction. Intuition is singular. Anxiety is plural. Intuition will often give you one answer, one scenario, one hypothetical, whereas anxiety
则会给你好几个。直觉也是立足于现在的、专注当下的。它基于当下正在发生的事情，而焦虑则专注于未来，并且非常具有强迫性。它植根于恐惧，而直觉则植根于自由。我想我能对这种区别做出的最好描述是：我们总是把焦虑误认为直觉，但反过来却极少发生。我们绝不会认为直觉仅仅是焦虑，因为直觉对自己是如此绝对地确信，而且通常没有任何恐惧。我知道这听起来有些抽象，所以我决定为你提供一份检查清单。
will give you several. Intuition is also present, focused. It's based on what is happening now, whilst anxiety is focused on the future and it's very obsessive. And it's based in fear, whereas intuition is based in freedom. I think the best way I can describe the difference is that we often confuse anxiety as intuition all the time, but very rarely the other way around. We never think that intuition is just anxiety, because intuition is so absolutely sure of itself, and there's often no fear. I know this feels rather abstract, so I thought I'd give you a bit of a checklist.
假设你正在收听这一集是为了解决你面临的具体情况。第一，我可能并不了解情况。不过确实有什么事要发生了。你内心某处感到害怕。你内心某处想要一个正确的答案。你内心某处不知道此刻该相信哪种感觉，又该忽略哪种感觉。所以我想要给你一份检查清单，来判断你脑海中的想法究竟是直觉还是焦虑。首先，你的想法是不是
Say you are listening to this episode for a specific situation to you. One, I probably don't know. There's something coming up, though. Some part of you is scared. Some part of you wants the right answer. Some part of you doesn't know which feeling you're having right now to trust and which one to ignore. So I want to give you a checklist for whether the thought you're having is an intuitive thought or an anxious thought. To begin with, does the thought you're having?
以“万一……”开头？如果是的话，这就是一个焦虑的想法。万一发生这种情况怎么办？而直觉是没有“万一”的。其次，你思考这个假设有多久了？如果它是持续且微妙的，那就是直觉。如果它只是今天刚刚出现，并且伴随着恐惧和过度思考一阵阵袭来，那就是焦虑。这个想法是限制了你还是扩展了你？
start with what if? If it does, it's an anxious thought. What if this happens? There's no what ifs with intuition. Secondly, how long have you been thinking about this hypothetical? If it's persistent and subtle, that's intuition. If it's just showed up today and it's coming in waves of fear and overthinking, that's anxiety. Does this thought limit or expand you?
如果它让你感到受困，那就是焦虑。因为焦虑确实喜欢通过保持现状来确保安全。如果它是直觉，它就会扩展你、引导你，哪怕这让你感到不舒服。这就是为什么我们不能仅凭“不舒服”来判断一个想法是直觉还是焦虑。现在，这个想法是更多地推动你建立自我信任，还是让你更加怀疑自己？自我信任属于直觉，自我怀疑属于焦虑。在这个决定上，你内心深处是感到自信的，还是在寻求不断的保证？也就是说，你会去问朋友、家人、Reddit论坛，试图搞清楚：这到底是不是正确的决定？
If it traps you, it's anxiety. because anxiety really likes to keep things safe by keeping them the same. If it's intuition, it's going to expand you and guide you, even if it feels uncomfortable. And that's why we cannot rely on discomfort alone to tell whether a thought is intuitive or anxious. Now, does this thought push you more towards self-trust or does it make you doubt yourself more? Self-trust, intuition, self-doubt, anxiety. Do you feel confident in this decision deep down or are you seeking constant reassurance? So are you going to friends, family, Reddit pages, trying to tell, is this the right decision?
这到底是不是正确的决定？如果你内心深处感到自信，那就是直觉。如果你需要得到别人的保证，那就是焦虑。如果你安静地坐着、呼吸、独自一人，并且觉得自己在努力让自己平静下来，那这个想法会消失吗？当你放松时，它会褪去吗？如果是这样的话，那就是焦虑。如果它依然存在且很稳定，并且没有对你造成任何伤害，那就是直觉。这就是我的检查清单。我希望你们把这些写下来。请记住，当你下一次再冒出一个你认为是焦虑的、具有误导性的想法时，这一集节目就在这里。用这个框架去检验它。我想，如果你依然
Is it not the right decision? If you feel confident deep down, it's intuition. If you're needing reassurance, it's anxiety. If you sit quietly and you breathe and you're all alone and you feel like you're trying to bring yourself peace, Does the thought go away? Does it fade when you relax? If that's the case, it's anxiety. If it's still there and it's steady, it's not causing you any harm, it's intuition. This is my checklist. And I want you to write these down. Remember that this episode is here for the next time you have a thought that you think is anxious, that you think is misleading. Test it against this framework. I think if you're so,
在费力分辨这两种情绪，那么真正能够区分它们的最终方法是：直觉会对行动做出积极的反应，而焦虑的想法则会对慢下来做出积极的反应。所以，如果你越无所作为，脑海中的想法声音就越大，那你就是把直觉和焦虑搞混了。如果你越是试图改变和逃避，脑海中的想法声音就越大，那你就是把焦虑和直觉搞混了。真的，我知道我给过你们很多分辨的方法，但这才是最根本的方法。考虑到这一切，我们该如何提升倾听内心声音、内心指引以及它对我们的期望的能力呢？
still struggling to delineate between these two emotions. The final way to really tell is that intuition is going to respond positively to action, and anxious thought will respond positively to slowing down. So, if the thought gets louder, the less you do, you have confused intuition with anxiety. If the thought gets louder, the more you try and change and escape, you've confused anxiety with intuition. That's really, I know I've given you a lot of ways of telling this, but this is really the one. With all that in mind, how do we improve our ability to hear our inner voice and our inner directive and what it wants from us?
事实上，我们又该如何提升屏蔽焦虑、阻止它压过直觉频率的能力呢？当我真的很想探寻自己内心真正的渴望和想法时，我做的第一件事就是花时间独处。我从一切事物中退后一步。我独自度过时光，特别是在大自然中。我发现，首先这能平静我的焦虑。我总是这么说。调节神经系统的最佳方法，就是把它放回它原本适应运作的环境中。你的神经系统，你的压力反应，它们是为
Matter of fact, how do we also improve our ability to tune out our anxiety and to stop it cutting over the intuitive frequency? The first thing I do when I really want to tap into what I truly want and I'm thinking is that I spend time in solitude. I take a step back from everything. I spend time by myself, particularly in nature. I find that firstly that calms my anxiety. I always say this. The best way to regulate your nervous system is to put it back into the environment it was made to work in. Your nervous system, your stress response, it was made.
大自然而生，是为所谓的这种自然栖息地而创造的。那是它能得到最好调节的地方。所以待在户外有助于做到这一点。它也让我更专注于我真正想要的东西。所以独处的那一部分真的、真的非常重要。我也认为，如果你正试图倾听你的直觉，花更多时间独处，不仅在某种程度上是治愈焦虑的良药，它还能阻止你寻求认同和意见。因为这通常是那些相当焦虑且思维强迫的人的共同特征，你经常不断地征求别人的意见，因为你无法信任自己。远离这种诱惑真的很有帮助。而且我认为，当我们不断寻求其他人对我们决定以及他们看法的验证时，
for the wild, it was made for this so-called natural habitat. That's where it's going to be regulated best. So being outdoors helps with that. It also makes me more focused on what I truly want. So that solitude part is really, really essential. I also think if you're trying to tap into your intuition, spending more time alone, it's not just that it's a cure for anxiety in some way. It's also that it stops you from approval and opinion seeking. So that is often a similar. of someone who was quite anxious and quite obsessive in their thoughts, you're often asking people for their opinion constantly because you can't trust yourself. Being away from that temptation is really helpful. And I think when we are constantly looking for other people's validation
我们就切断了与自我认知的联系，因为我们开始质疑自己的想法，转而偏爱别人的想法。说真的，他们又知道什么呢？他们对你的感受又了解多少？可能并不多。他们是在把对自己人生的直觉套用到你的情况上，而你的情况可能完全不同。实际上，2023年在澳大利亚进行过一项令人难以置信的研究发现，我们当中那些花更多时间独处的人，自我意识更强，在自主性方面也更满足。自主性是指我们为自己做决定并相信它们是好决定的能力。现在我要在这里做一个小小的警告，你不能把超过75%的时间用来
of our decisions and what they think, we do cut ourselves off from our self-knowledge because our own thoughts, we start to question them in favor of what someone else thinks. And really, what do they know? Like what do they know about what you feel? Probably not much. They're applying their own intuition about their life to your circumstances when your circumstances are probably entirely different. And there's this incredible study from 2023 actually conducted in Australia that found those of us who spend more time alone, we are more self-aware and we are more satisfied in terms of autonomy. Autonomy being our ability to make decisions for ourselves and believe they are good decisions. Now I will say small caveat here, you can't spend more than 75% of your time
独处。另一项研究也给出了这个数字，同样是2023年的另一项研究。所以，在能够欣赏独处和某种意义上的孤立之间找到平衡，同时又不要走向极端，这真的很重要。增强直觉的另一种方法是保持耐心。不要总是寻找征兆。不要急于求成。急于求成是一场焦虑的游戏。那是焦虑最爱玩的游戏。它会让你在根本没有征兆的地方去寻找征兆，导致你对小事过度解读，从而做出错误的决定。我基本上想表达的是，不要觉得你需要一次性改变所有事情，也不要觉得每一次的不适都是一个问题。有时不适，就是成长。
alone. Another study kind of gave us that figure, also another study from 2023. So finding that balance between being able to appreciate solitude and isolation in a sense, but also not tip too far over the edge, really important. The other way to strengthen your intuition is to be patient. Don't always look for a sign. Don't rush it. Rushing is an anxious game. That is anxiety's favorite game to play. And it will have you looking for signs where there aren't any, leading you to read too much into small things, leading you to make the wrong decisions. Basically what I'm trying to say is don't feel like you need to change everything at once and that every discomfort is a problem. sometimes discomfort, it is growth.
在一个感觉陌生和奇怪的时期待上一会儿是没问题的，不要觉得这就代表出了问题。让我举几个这样的例子。当你处于一段新的恋爱关系中时，特别是如果你之前曾经历过一段不健康的关系，有时这会让人觉得有点痛苦。关系中总是会有这种成长的阵痛。但这并不意味着你应该全盘相信那种不适感。另一个例子是在一份新工作中。
It is okay to sit in a period that feels strange and odd for a little while without feeling like it's indicating a problem. Let me give some examples of this. When you are in a new relationship, especially if you're in a new relationship where you've previously been in an unhealthy one, sometimes that's going to feel a little bit painful. There are these growing pains in a relationship. it doesn't mean that you should trust that discomfort solely. Another example is in a new job.
你知道，我总是说新工作的前三个月真的、真的很难。但这并不意味着这是一个错误的决定。比如搬到一个新城市呢？这也是一个例子。你会感到不舒服。当你搬到一个新城市时，这种不适感并不意味着你一定做错了决定。我的原则一直是六个月原则。如果一份工作是三个月，那新城市就是六个月。
You know, I always say the first three months of a new job are really, really hard. It doesn't mean it's the wrong decision. What about like moving to a new city? That's another one. You're going to feel uncomfortable. When you move to a new city, that discomfort does not mean that you necessarily have made the wrong decision. My rule is always the six-month rule. if it's three months for a job, it's six months for a new city.
如果在六个月时你依然讨厌它，那么你可以说：“好吧，也许我当时确实没有相信自己的直觉。”但是，是的，我只是觉得对你做出的选择保持耐心，它们现在没有进展并不意味着你错了。我还要反过来建议：注意你过去做决定时的模式。回顾一下你做出错误决定的那些时刻。
If you still hate it at six months, then you can say, oh, maybe I didn't trust my gut instinct. But yeah, I just think that be patient with choices that you make, just because they aren't working out right now, doesn't mean that you were wrong. I would also say in the opposite direction, notice patterns in past decisions. So reflect on times when you made the wrong decision.
可以说，坦白讲，我确实做出了一个错误的决定。就在你做出那个决定之前的几个星期、几天、几分钟里，是不是有另一个决定在呼唤你，却被你忽略了？那可能就是你的直觉。那可能就是你的内心指引。还记得那种感觉吗？记住它，并把它应用到你现在所处的情境中。
You can arguably say, Tang, I really made a wrong decision. Right before you made that decision in the weeks, days, minutes before you made that decision, was there another decision calling you that you ignored? That was probably your gut instinct. That was probably your intuition. Remember that feeling? Remember it and apply it to the situations you're in now.
你现在是否有似曾相识的感觉？去尝试通过试错来检验。你知道，有时与直觉建立更多联系的最佳方法，就是犯下那些能向你证明你的直觉是什么的错误。试错很糟糕，但有时如果你对某事有强烈的感受，你就必须坚持到底，看看会发生什么，这将是让你区分“焦虑对你而言是什么感觉”与“直觉对你而言是什么感觉”的最简单方法。如果这听你可以从非常微小、风险极低的事情开始，通过做出微小的直觉决定来建立对直觉的信心。
Do you feel something similar at the moment? And try some trial and error. You know, sometimes the best way to get more in touch with your intuition is to make mistakes that prove to you what your intuition is not. Trial and error sucks, but sometimes if you feel strongly about something, you have to follow through with it, see what happens, and that's going to be the easiest way for you to tell what anxiety feels like for you versus what intuition feels like for you. And if that feels very big and scary, you can start with very small, low stakes risks, just to build confidence in your intuition by making minor intuitive decisions.
比如尝试一项新活动，如果你觉得脑海里有个声音叫你跟街上的人说说话，如果你觉得受到召唤去——我不知道——与某人建立联系，那就去做吧。这风险太低了。我觉得不会有什么问题的。诸如此类的事情是非常棒的练习日常。它们就像是很好的学步车。至于管理焦虑，这完全是另一回事，是个完全不同的深坑。正如我所说，我们有一集专门讲这个。我会把它放在节目简介里。这其实可能是在听完这一集之后非常值得去听的一期节目。
So trying a new activity, if you feel called to talk to someone on the street, if you feel called to, I don't know, have a connection with someone, do it. It's so low stakes. I feel like it's going to be fine. Those kinds of things are a really great practice routine. They're really good training wheels. Now for managing your anxiety, this is a whole other ballgame, a whole other pit of snakes. Like I said, we have an episode on this. I'm going to leave it in the description. It's actually probably a really good episode to listen to right after this one.
但快速说一下当我感到焦虑来袭时我是如何应对的。我列了一张“恐惧与现实”清单。什么是恐惧的想法？什么是现实的想法？我把它们列在不同的两边。我对自己重复这些话，以便重新确认我所知道的真实情况。挑战“万一”式的思维。问问自己：如果最坏的情况没有发生，而是发生了最好的情况呢？
But rapid fire how I address my anxiety when I feel like it's taking over. I create a fear versus reality list. What is a fear thought? What is a reality thought? I put them on separate sides. I repeat them to myself so that I can just reaffirm what I do know to be true. Challenge the what if thinking. Ask yourself, what if the best case scenario happened?
这种情况发生的几率有多大？它不会比最坏情况发生的几率多，也不会少。跟其他人聊聊你的感受。我还要说，如果你正经历一段非常焦虑的时期，并且它干扰了你倾听直觉的能力，请戒酒。请戒酒。我们知道，酒精最初通过大脑中的GABA活动产生非常平静的效果，从而使焦虑激增。但随着酒精药效消退，大脑试图用谷氨酸来重新平衡这些神经递质，
What's the chances of that happening? No more, no less than the worst case. Talk to other people about the feelings that you're having. I would also say stop drinking if you're going through a real anxious period and it's interrupting your ability to hear from your intuition. Please stop drinking. We know that alcohol spikes anxiety by initially causing a very calming effect through gabber activity in the brain. But then as it wears off, the brain tries to rebalance those neurotransmitters with glutamate,
而谷氨酸是一种会引发焦虑的神经递质兼激素，这会让我们感到更加焦虑。请戒酒。做一些运动。如果我很焦虑，并且心里在想：“好吧，为什么我的直觉/焦虑告诉我这个朋友讨厌我？为什么我突然相信自己会被驱逐？为什么我相信这个、那个、那个？”我就会立刻跳舞、摇晃身体、唱歌，做某种运动来驱散这种对我而言的身体反应。还有，去做心理咨询。去做心理咨询。
which is a very anxious neurotransmitter slash hormone, causing us to feel more anxious. Please stop drinking. Engage in some kind of movement. If I'm anxious and I'm like, okay, why does my intuition slash anxiety tell me this friend hates me? Why do I suddenly believe I'm going to get evicted? Why do I believe this, that, that I immediately dance, I shake, I sing, I do some kind of movement to dispel what is a physical reaction for me. And also get therapy. Get therapy.
人们经常谈论它，因为它真的管用。意不意外，惊不惊喜？这太神奇了。所以，如果你真的想顺应你的直觉，有时你确实需要清理掉一些垃圾。有时你确实需要清理掉随着时间推移为了保护自己而培养出来的、但实际上却在伤害你的思维模式。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我们将解答一些听众关于焦虑和直觉的困惑。请继续收听。
People talk about it a lot because it actually works. Surprise, surprise. It's amazing. And so if you really want to tap into your intuition, sometimes you do have to clean out some of the garbage. Sometimes you do have to clean out. some of the thought patterns that you have developed over time to protect yourself that actually are hurting you. All right, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, we've got some listener dilemmas to do with anxiety and intuition. Stay with us.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康 and 健身专家等展开对话，带你抛开主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是TWO percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什他妈的跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集节目中，我们都会来到这里，剖析发生的事件，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，不过只是让大家知道我的态度。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在了台面上。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush I gotta do a little Kim. Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，这个月我将把我十多年来在心理健康领域的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要？
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
你当一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马拉尼尼。我的世界观崩塌了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
这就是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
作死就会付出代价。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》这个全新的季度中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《The Girlfriends》。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。所以，我可爱的听众们，如果你是节目的忠实听众，已经关注了一段时间，你就会知道这是本播客一个相对较新的环节。我只是在接下来的几期节目中试行一下。我随时欢迎大家的反馈，但是你们中有那么多人会在节目播出后产生疑问。而我真希望自己能在正片里回答那些问题。所以现在我给你们所有人一个机会，让你们在节目播出前就可以向我提出那些具体的问题、你们正在经历的困惑，这样我就可以为你们解答了。
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
如果你想为即将推出的主题提交问题，只需确保关注了我的账号@That Psychology Podcast。我们接下来将推出一些非常酷的节目，围绕自信、大器晚成、拟社会关系等主题。我会向大家征集问题和困惑。如果你讨厌这个环节，请务必让我知道。我真的很想听到真实的想法，因为如果你们不喜欢它，这个环节就要被取消、取消、取消，彻底没了。
So my lovely listeners, if you are a loyal listener of the show, you have been here for a while, you will know that this is a relatively new segment of the podcast. I'm just trialing it out for the next couple of episodes. I'm always down for your feedback, but so many of you would have questions after the episode had gone up. And I wish that I could have answered those questions in the actual episode. So now I'm giving you all the opportunity to ask me those specific questions, dilemmas that you are having before the episode air so I can answer them for you.
但我想回答今天大家善意提交的一些问题。我们来聊聊第一个问题。被焦虑引领，有没有哪怕任何一次或任何一种情况是一件好事？答案是肯定的。所以焦虑会引发痛苦（distress）和激越压力（eustress）。拼写是E-U-S-T-R-E-S-S。它也被称为积极压力，它有助于提升许多非常棒的事情，特别是我们的动机和专注力。
If you want to submit a question for an upcoming topic, just make sure you're following me at That Psychology Podcast. We've got some really cool episodes coming up around confidence, around being a late bloomer, around parasocial relationships. I will be asking for your questions and your dilemmas. If you hate this segment, please actually let me know. I really want to hear it because if you guys don't like it, it's going, it's going, it's going, it's gone.
所以有一个定律叫做耶基斯-多德森定律（Yerkes-Dodson law）。基本上它的意思是，焦虑在一定程度内其实有助于提升我们的表现。当然，适度的焦虑水平可以帮你更好地学习。它们能帮人们赶上截止日期。但只有当我们达到过度的程度时，它才真正开始对我们造成伤害。所以从本质上讲，保持一个重要的平衡是很重要的。焦虑也有助于表明什么时候有什么事情需要我们的我知道TikTok和Instagram上有很多帖子都在说“我是如何摆脱焦虑的”、
But I want to answer some of the questions that a lot of you kindly submitted today. Let's talk about this first question. Is there any such thing or any time when being led by anxiety is a good thing? The answer is yes. So anxiety causes distress and eustress. U-S-T-R-E-S. It's also known as good stress and it helps boost a lot of really great things, specifically our motivation and our focus.
“我通过运动治愈了焦虑”、“我不再感到焦虑了”。这可能并不是什么好事。有时你确实需要焦虑。否则你就会一直处于一种完全平静和正常的绝对状态中，甚至当有压力的事情发生时，你也不会做出反应。有这种感觉是很重要的。想想你的婚礼或者某个非常重要的活动，
So there's this law called the Yerkes-Dodson law. And basically it says that anxiety up to a point actually helps improve our performance. Moderate levels of anxiety, of course, will help you better with studying. They help people with deadlines. But it's when we get to an excessive point that it really starts to kind of hurt us. So essentially it's an important balance to have. Anxiety also helps indicate when something requires our attention. I know there are a lot of posts on TikTok and Instagram being like how I got rid of my anxiety.
你对它产生了深刻的情感反应。你感到紧张。你感到害怕。你感到兴奋。所有这一切之所以成为可能，都是因为焦虑。所以，某种程度的焦虑确实很重要。第二个问题。我的直觉告诉我应该离开我的男朋友，
I cured my anxiety with exercise. I no longer feel anxious. That's probably not a good thing. You do need anxiety sometimes. Otherwise you would be just in a constant state of complete calm and normalcy. and even when stressful things happened, you wouldn't respond to them. It's important to feel that way. Think about your wedding day or like some really important event
但充满焦虑的我却在想，这会不会只是一种自我破坏。这只是一个人的问题，但我在私信里收到类似问题的次数简直惊人。显然，这是你们很多人都相当担心的事情，我懂。我真的懂，因为你可能在和某个非常、非常nice且很好的人约会，但你还很年轻，你会担心：这真的是最适合我的吗？你无法判断自己以后会不会后悔，
where you feel a deep emotional sensation in response to it. You feel nervous. You feel scared. You feel excited. All of that is possible because of anxiety. So yes, there is some level that is important. Question number two. My gut says to leave my boyfriend,
或者这到底是不是一个你需要继续前行的信号。你不想浪费对方的时间。我在这里基本上所描述的，就是恋爱焦虑或恋爱强迫症（relationship OCD）。不要被这个术语迷惑了。它与我们通常所见的强迫症没有任何关系。本质上，这是你对恋爱关系的一种高度警惕感，在这种状态下，你不断寻找可能出错的事情，不是因为对方是个坏人，而是因为你担心自己会做出错误的选择。
but my anxious self-wonder. if it's just self-sabotage. This is just one person's question, but the amount of times I got something very similar in my DMs was incredible. It's something that a lot of you are obviously quite worried about, and I get it. I really get it because you might be dating someone really, really nice and wonderful, but you're still so young and you worry, is this really what's right for me? You can't tell whether you're going to regret it,
但我焦虑的自我怀疑：这只是自我破坏吗？这只是一个人的问题，但我收到的私信中类似的问题多得惊人。显然，这是你们很多人都相当担心的事情，我懂。我真的懂，因为你可能在和某一个非常好、非常棒的人约会，但你还那么年轻，你会担心，这真的是适合我的吗？你无法判断你是会后悔这样做，
or whether this is really a sign that you need to move on. You don't want to waste their time. What I'm basically describing right here is relationship anxiety or relationship OCD. Don't let the term fool you. It has nothing to do with how we typically see OCD. Essentially, it's this real sense of hypervigilance towards your relationship, whereby you're constantly looking for things that could go wrong, not because they're a bad person, but because you're worried about making the wrong choice.
还是这真的是你需要离开的信号。你不想浪费他们的时间。我在这里所描述的基本上是恋爱焦虑或恋爱强迫症。不要被这个术语所迷惑。它与我们通常所理解的强迫症毫无关系。从本质上讲，这是对你的关系的一种真正的过度警惕感，在这种状态下，你不断地寻找可能出错的地方，不是因为对方是个坏人，而是因为你担心做出错误的选择。
It sounds like that's something that you may be battling with. On the other hand, it may be a deeper sign. You've noticed something about who you two are as a couple, maybe not consciously yet, but you're feeling it first in your gut. Here's what I would say to you. If you're thinking about what it would look like to leave him more than you are thinking about your future with him, it's probably not the right relationship. The other question I would ask you is,
听起来这可能是你正在挣扎的事情。另一方面，这可能是一个更深层的信号。你已经注意到了你们两个作为伴侣之间的一些不对劲，也许还没有意识到，但你的直觉首先感受到了。我想对你说的是：如果你脑子里想要离开他的想法，多过想要和他共度未来的想法，那这可能就不是一段合适的感情。我要问你的另一个问题是，
if you knew you would find love again soon, if you knew that there was someone else out there who would love you as much as this person loves you now, would you leave? Is this just a safe place to land? Is this just an in the meantime relationship? I think be really, really honest with yourself. Also acknowledge, and some people might not be happy with me,
如果你知道自己很快就能再次找到真爱，如果你知道外面还有另一个人会像现在这个人一样爱你，你会离开吗？这里只是一个安全的避风港吗？这只是一段过渡期的感情吗？我觉得你需要对自己非常、非常诚实。同时也要承认——有些人可能不会高兴我这么说——
for saying this, but you don't need to make a decision right now. Like I said, intuition gives you time. Anxiety wants you to make a decision right now. Relationships naturally go through ebbs and flows and hard points and great points. It might just be that you're in a bit of a rut right now. I wouldn't want you to give up a really amazing relationship because you've been sold this idea that couples can never have low points. So that's my advice on that one. Question number three asked over. over on Instagram, when do you know if you should push through a comfort zone or if it's actually just unsafe? Good question. It's hard to tell. My natural desire is to always push through. I think that discomfort is something that we as humans are not good at managing, especially in a world where
但你现在不需要做出决定。就像我说的，直觉会给你留出时间。而焦虑则希望你立刻做出决定。感情自然会经历起伏、艰难期和高光期。可能只是因为你们现在陷入了一段平淡期。我不希望你因为被灌输了“情侣绝不能有低谷”这种观念，就放弃一段非常棒的感情。这就是我对这个问题的建议。第三个问题来自Instagram上的提问：什么时候你才知道自己应该突破舒适区，还是说这其实根本就不安全？好问题。这很难分辨。我天生的渴望总是去突破。我认为不适感是我们人类不擅长应对的事情，尤其是在这样一个世界里：
we don't have to be that uncomfortable if we don't want to be. You know, we truly don't. We can be warm at all times. Most of us, thank gosh, can have food in our belly at all times. We don't experience extreme discomfort anymore. Sometimes a little bit of discomfort is a good thing in this situation, unless you can point to evidence that this is actually going to be an unsafe thing. So can you see examples of it? I think about this with traveling. Are there stories of people being kidnapped in the country you're going to? Are there stories of, or I don't know, Google reviews that the zip line you're going to do is a little bit dangerous. It's important not to be arrogant. Just because we are trusting our intuition doesn't mean that we ignore anxiety at all
如果我们不想感到不适，我们就真的可以不必那么不适。你知道的，我们确实可以。我们可以随时保持温暖。谢天谢地，我们大多数人可以随时吃饱饭。我们再也不会经历极端的不适了。有时候，在特定情况下，一点点不适是一件好事，除非你能指出证据证明这实际上是一件不安全的事情。那么你能看到这样的例子吗？我以旅行举例。你去的那个国家有绑架人的故事吗？有相关的故事吗？或者我不知道，谷歌评论说你要玩的滑索有点危险？重要的是不要傲慢。我们信任直觉并不意味着我们在任何时候都完全忽视焦虑。
points. It is still an important resource. So when you're feeling like there is something that's holding you back and you think that it's because it's unsafe, investigate the evidence for that thing, take a couple of minutes to walk yourself back from the situation. and see it more clearly. I also would say do things to make whatever you're going through feel more safe, but still keep going. So I'm trying to think of what you might be talking about. Say it's your career.
它仍然是一个重要的资源。所以，当觉得有什么东西在阻碍你，而你认为是因为它不安全时，去调查支持这种说法的证据，花几分钟让自己从那个情境中抽离出来，更清楚地看待它。我还要说的是，做一些事情来让你所经历的事情感觉更安全，但同时依然要继续前进。所以我在想要说的是什么。假设是你的职业。
It feels uncomfortable. You think that that's a sign that you're doing the wrong thing. Try and make ways to make your career the way that you're pushing it more comfortable. So try and find different income streams to keep yourself financially stable. maybe that's the source of the discomfort whilst still pushing forward. I think that's like a really great way to say it. Like, you know, people didn't stop building skyscrapers because it was unsafe or uncomfortable.
这让你感到不适。你认为这是你做错了事的信号。试着想办法让你的职业朝着你正在推进的方向变得更舒适。所以试着寻找不同的收入来源来保持财务稳定，也许这就是不适感的来源，同时还要继续前进。我觉得这是一个很好的表达方式。就像，你知道的，人们并没有因为建造摩天大楼不安全或不舒服就停止建造它们。
They kept building them and they built them with safety measures. I think you can do the same in your life. I don't know why I just suddenly used a construction metaphor. I think that's the first time that's ever happened during this podcast. So whoever's questioned that is, you should feel very privileged. All right. final question, I get visceral morning scarries when I wake up. Is it my body trying to tell me something? This is a great question. It's a great question because I get this a lot. I get morning scaries,
他们继续建造，并采取了安全措施来建造它们。我想你也可以在生活中这样做。我不知道为什么我突然用了一个建筑比喻。我想这是在这个播客中破天荒第一次。所以提出那个问题的人，你应该感到非常荣幸。好了，最后一个问题：我醒来时有一种发自内心的早晨恐惧感（morning scaries）。这是我的身体在试图告诉我什么吗？这是一个很好的问题。这是一个很好的问题，因为我经常遇到这种情况。我也会有早晨恐惧感，
probably like five days a week. In terms of whether it's trying to tell you something like about your future or about your life in a mystical way, I don't think so. I think what you're probably experiencing is an elevated cortisol awakening response. So that's morning anxiety. Basically, when you wake up, sometimes we can have this huge surge in our stress hormone cortisol. It's meant to help us just be alive and awake to the world. When that's dysregulated, it can actually go too far the other way and make us quite anxious. It's important not to read too much into it. sometimes I think we can have those again very visceral emotional responses and say that's a sign something's wrong I have cancer someone's going to die no I think that there's often the simplest responses the best one focus on your sleep hygiene focus on trying to bring down your cortisol levels and your stress response before before going to bed and after waking up so no phone in your bedroom you have no idea what a bright blue light in your face before you go to bed and right after you wake up does to your stress response
大概一周有五天吧。至于它是否试图以某种神秘的方式向你传达关于你的未来或生活的事情，我觉得并没有。你经历的可能只是升高的皮质醇觉醒反应。这就是早晨焦虑。基本上，当你醒来时，有时我们的压力激素皮质醇会大幅激增。它本意是帮助我们保持对世界的清醒和活力。当它失调时，实际上可能会走向另一个极端，让我们变得非常焦虑。重要的是不要过度解读它。有时我认为我们又会产生那种非常强烈的、发自内心的情绪反应，然后说这是出问题的信号：我有癌症，有人要死了。不，我认为通常最简单的回应就是最好的回应：关注你的睡眠卫生，专注于在睡前和醒来后降低你的皮质醇水平和压力反应。所以卧室里不要放手机，你根本不知道在你睡觉前和醒来后，强烈的蓝光直射你的脸会对你的压力反应
and your circadian rhythm so try and control that try not to have any bright lights in the bedroom and also review your alarm schedule so it's actually best to wake up naturally at the end of a full sleep cycle if your alarm is like waking you up at like six hours and 55 minutes maybe do it for like seven and a half hours and try and go to bed earlier or get that sleep in because if you're waking up in the middle of a sleep schedule you're waking up in the middle of a dream you're waking up in the middle of REM sleep you are going to be more anxious so again simplest solution is probably the best one I don't think that this is a sign of anything or trying to tell you something other than that your sleep patterns are maybe just a little bit off
和昼夜节律造成多大的影响，所以试着控制这一点，尽量不要在卧室里开强光，还要检查你的闹钟计划。实际上，最好是在一个完整睡眠周期的结束时自然醒来。如果你的闹钟是在比如说6小时55分钟时把你叫醒，也许把它设定为7个半小时左右，试着早点睡或者把觉睡够，因为如果你在一个睡眠周期的中间醒来，在梦境的中间醒来，在快速眼动睡眠的中间醒来，你会更加焦虑。所以，最简单的解决办法可能就是最好的办法。我不认为这是任何事情的征兆，也没有试图告诉你什么，除了你的睡眠模式可能只是有点失调之外，
and if it keeps happening go and see a doctor they have these really cool sleep studies right now and see if you're feeling it in other areas of your life. If you're not feeling it in other areas of your life, I do think it's just linked back to what this is. I think that is all the questions that I have for today. I'm just reviewing my notes and it looks like that is the case. A long episode, if you have made it this far, you know the deal, a special emoji coming your way.
如果这种情况一直发生，去看看医生。他们现在有非常酷的睡眠研究，看看你在生活的其他领域是否也感受到了这一点。如果你在生活的其他领域没有感受到，我确实认为这只是跟这个有关。我想这就是我今天所有的提问了。我正在检查我的笔记，看起来确实如此。这是一集很长的节目，如果你能听到这里，你知道规矩，一个特殊的表情符号正在向你走来。
I want you to leave an emoji that best represents to you what intuition feels like. what does it feel like in your body? What does it feel like in your soul, in your limbs, in your brain? If you've made it that far, this far, I mean, let me know in the comments using that little sneaky sign. As always, I want to thank you for listening. I really loved this episode. Sometimes you just make an episode and you think, fuck, sorry to swear, but like, fuck, I really like this episode. I really like this episode, so I appreciate you listening this far. make sure that you are following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. We are doing more like listener questions.
我希望你留下一个最能代表你对直觉感受的表情符号。它在你的身体里感觉是什么样的？它在你的灵魂里、在你的四肢里、在你的大脑里感觉是什么样的？如果你已经走到了这一步，我是说走到这里，请在评论区用那个小小的暗号让我知道。一如既往，我要感谢你的收听。我真的很喜欢这一集。有时你只是做了一集节目，然后你会想，他妈的——抱歉爆粗口，但是——他妈的，我真的很喜欢这一集。我真的很喜欢这一集，所以我感谢你能听到这里。确保你在Instagram上关注我，账号是that psychology podcast。我们正在做更多类似听众提问的内容。
So if you want to get involved in some upcoming episodes, that's a great way to do it. Also, if you feel like there is a friend of yours who could really benefit from this episode, make sure to share it with them. I would love to hear from you. I would love to see more people listening, more people following, more people giving us a five-star review if you feel called to do so. But thanks again. Thanks for coming along with me on this really fun. episode ride. Until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk
所以如果你想参与即将到来的节目，这是一个很好的方式。另外，如果你觉得你的某个朋友真的可以从这一集节目中受益，请务必分享给他们。我很乐意听到你的声音，我很想看到更多的人收听，更多的人关注，如果你的内心有所触动，给我们一个五星好评。但再次感谢。谢谢你陪我一起度过这段非常有趣的节目之旅。直到下次，保持安全。保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们
very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier war fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、健康和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。
On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年代。我的意思是，那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at it”。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人克尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方真的都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试做了两次手脚，对吗？我只对测试做了一次手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是由真人制作的。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。